salut c'est Freddie Highmore pour brute
[Music]
mr.  Wonka
[Musique]
J'ai eu beaucoup de chance d'avoir grandi à
Londres et en quelque sorte loin de vous
savez, votre genre d'éducation stéréotypée à
Hollywood en tant que telle et oui, je
pense que le simple fait d'avoir cette
distance entre une vie normale que je
pourrais  revenir à et vous savez être à l'
école et vouloir être footballeur
et cela m'a aidé à ne pas être défini
comme un acteur en tant que tel c'est drôle je
n'ai jamais eu l'impression de venir d'une
famille de l'industrie du tout mon tu sais que ma mère est  un
agent mais mon père n'a pas
joué du tout depuis que je suis né et
il s'est en quelque sorte occupé de mon frère et moi
qui m'a donné une enfance normale et tout
le jeu d'acteur que j'ai eu la chance de faire était
quelque chose  qui est venu je suppose que du côté
de cela
[Music]
ce n'est pas comme si j'avais une
grande croisade contre les médias sociaux en
tant que tels, je pense que quand j'étais jeune
et que filmer les médias sociaux n'était pas vraiment
une chose et donc je  Je n'ai jamais vraiment
pris l'habitude de l'utiliser
et je suppose que  en quelque sorte continué
jusqu'à aujourd'hui simplement en
allant à l'université et en continuant à l'
école, vous acquérez plus d'expérience
ultime dans la vie qui ne sera finalement
utile que lorsque vous déciderez
de vous consacrer à quelque chose
bien sûr il y a le  une partie de tout le monde
qui veut dire suivez vos rêves et
abandonnez tout pour y
parvenir, mais je pense que la réponse est réaliste et
je suppose que c'est ce que j'ai fait et que j'ai fini par
avoir de la chance en le faisant, mais vous savez que le jeu n'est
pas l'objectif  de mon
enfance et d'aller à l'université et
d'avoir la possibilité de faire d'
autres choses pour que, lorsque vous serez un
adulte et que vous soyez en quelque sorte prêt à prendre
cette décision de ce que vous pourriez vouloir
faire à temps plein, vous  avez le choix de
ce que vous de ce que vous voulez faire
vous